okay well mr. King Shawn King glad to
have you here welcome yeah well I wish I
could say I was happy to be here but I
felt it was a necessity so you know I I
guess congratulations are in order first
for your new gig in 2017 how'd you get
the job at the young turks by the way
yeah well I wish there was a better
story about it to tell but in actuality
I just happen to be in the YouTube lobby
I guess that's as good a reason as any
its it seems like a good match The Young
Turks deny the Armenian Genocide and you
deny that you're a white guy you're both
living in the Sandero universe you know
that's funny right for a white
supremacist like yourself maybe uh but
no they don't really do background
checks at TYT plus i think they just
like the idea of hanging out with a
black man so but Shawn you're not you're
not black you know that you're not a not
a black man yeah how do I know right
Steven that that was going to come up
your factual inaccuracies are outrageous
and litigious and they're just factually
not factual Steven uh my mom was white
that's correct but she also happened to
be like a really big [ __ ] and I don't
know who my daddy is so I could be what
up no you Shawn no we do know you here
we have pictures here nukkie dear let's
bring this up we have pictures of you as
a child as you can clearly see here the
first one you're not black they don't
let hair almost look strawberry blonde
frankly uh and here you're clearly also
not black and there you are in your
teenage phase Cabbage Patch dolls from
the 40s and you throw your mom or do you
throw your mom out of the bus like that
Shawn there's nothing less black than
trashing your mom even rappers will
shoot someone with one hand and hug
their mom with the other eye
I don't know what you're thinking you're
clearly not a black man oh I'm sorry is
this a part where you the white man
tells me what a black man should be like
I shouldn't be calling my mom a [ __ ]
because what you want the black man
dance for you like your what like I'm
your house white black guy all right
well Shawn here's something else we know
that on the police report you filed the
notorious report claiming you were the
victim of a hate crime
you checked we have this appear a box
indicating that you were Caucasian and
why are you playing your nostrils
what is that don't do that what is
always with the flowing out of the
hospitals and in every picture I don't
know what okay if the literal
photographic evidence isn't enough here
we have some more pictures that would
certainly insinuate you are likely not a
black person this is circumstantial
here's a picture of you at a high school
swim meet you know that that you look
actually good form here you are skiing
in Aspen nah my apologies and here you
are at what appears to be a Nickelback
concert okay I would never be caught
dead and a Nickelback concert was Creed
okay so I wear the Young Turks your
first choice or how did you end up there
what was the progression mr. king yeah
well you know I have long respected The
Young Turks and their commitment you
know to journalistic like integrity
actually he did apply to other places
now see there you go with your lies
again you know right in Sean's defense
knock a charity how would you how would
you even know well you played you played
to hear a lot louder with Crowder yeah
he applied here yeah I got a gun
application he Evans resume can we bring
it up yeah Sean yeah you know what I did
in fact apply at louder with Crowder
right simply as a social experiment
regarding systemic white supremacy and
congratulations you did exactly what I
thought you would do
you know you you showcase classic racism
xenophobia biracial phobia your guess is
as good as mine race phobia homophobia
but whether it's on your you're gay like
I could be so truthfully though without
trepidation like I just put that there
as a test you know to hedge my bets and
to make sure yeah I want some chocolate
milk that still sounds nice okay Shawn
that's uncomfortable I hope you find
what you're looking for in life Shawn
King everybody we have Gary Sinise
coming up next
[Music]
you